Posters are often the first way to get moviegoers
excited for the next big release.
The trick for a studio's marketing team is
to tease something cool about their upcoming
movies without giving away too much.
Considering that a poster is just one picture,
you would think that wouldn't be too difficult.
But sometimes designers get a little too excited
and present an image that somehow manages
to reveal way too much.
Maybe they thought audiences wouldn't notice
or wouldn't care, but they can't deny that
these posters ruined the entire movie.
In case the title of this video didn’t tip
you off, warning, massive movie spoilers ahead.
Prometheus
There's a lot about Prometheus that audiences
might find confusing, and that's beyond Michael
Fassbender's unnerving portrayal of an android
named David.
Character motivations are murky, the setting
is sometimes obscure, and the whole thing
is supposed to be a prequel to Alien.
There are plenty of quiet moments, which are
not common in a modern sci-fi movie, but eventually
Prometheus gets around to what we all go to
the movies to see: big-budget, CGI explosions.
The film's action peaks when two gleaming,
futuristic spaceships crash into each other
while humans watch from below.
You might recognize this climactic, eye-popping
scene from the poster, as the explosion is
the key image.
Split
M. Night Shyamalan's Unbreakable stars Bruce
Willis as a Philadelphia man named David Dunn
who comes to realize that he's nearly invincible,
while crossing paths with his villainous opposite,
the fragile-boned Elijah Price, a.k.a. Mr.
Glass.
When it was released in 2000, Willis announced
that the film was part of a planned trilogy.
But a sequel never materialized... until it
did, when nobody was looking.
In 2017, Shyamalan had his biggest hit in
years with the psychological thriller Split,
starring James McAvoy as a disturbed man with
24 separate personalities who kidnaps a trio
of teenage girls.
At the end, he escapes, and viewers learn
more details about the man on the loose via
a news report playing on a TV in a diner.
"And they gave him a funny name, too.
What was it?"
"Mr. Glass.”
Split was set in the same universe as Unbreakable
all along.
Who knew?
Fans who remembered both posters, that's who.
The two images share a virtually identical
breaking glass pattern.
The average moviegoer might have missed it,
but for Shyamalan diehards, the Split poster
gave away its big reveal ahead of time.
Avengers: Infinity War
In the box office behemoth Avengers: Infinity
War, intergalactic villain Thanos completes
his savage quest for the Infinity Stones.
He uses them to instantaneously wipe out half
of all life in the universe, including many
of the superheroes assembled by the Avengers
to stop him.
For a studio to kill off so many beloved money-makers
always comes as something of a surprise, even
if most of them will presumably come back
to life in the sequel.
But if you were a Japanese-fluent fan who
saw the Japanese poster, you had those sacrifices
spoiled by the tagline, which translates to
"Avengers, totally annihilated."
"I don't wanna go.
I don’t wanna go, sir, please.
Please, I don’t wanna go.
I don’t wanna go."
Deadpool 2
Both the content and marketing of the Deadpool
films are rife with sarcasm, self-awareness,
and self-deprecation.
That silliness was on full display in the
Deadpool 2 poster, which looks like a '60s
Italian spy movie crossed with Smokey and
the Bandit.
Such a piece of promotional art would have
to include the funniest, smarmiest, and most
sarcastic tagline possible.
While the Deadpool team could have just spoiled
their own movie, they instead decided to reveal
the ending of another movie set in Fox's X-Men
universe.
Logan, which was released a year before Deadpool
2, marked the last time Hugh Jackman would
lead a movie as the Wolverine.
That fact was made quite clear by the Deadpool
2 poster, which featured the tagline "From
the studio that killed Wolverine."
Carrie
The 1976 teen horror classic Carrie is about
a teenage girl kept sheltered away from the
world by her domineering and deeply troubled
mother.
Why?
Because Carrie can do powerful things with
her telekinetic mind.
Insecure and socially awkward, she's bullied
by the other kids at school, and it all comes
to a head at the prom.
Mean girl Norma gets Carrie elected prom queen
as a joke.
Carrie thinks she's finally won over her horrible
classmates, until they soak her with a bucket
of pig's blood.
That sets off Carrie, who uses the full extent
of her mental powers to kill pretty much everyone
present.
It's the climax of the film, and it's revealed
on the poster: happy, prom queen Carrie juxtaposed
next to angry, blood-drenched Carrie.